[Music]
uh as we'll see later in the talk though
uh it might also be why not active
learning but that's we'll get there um
so hi everyone my name is Vincent I'm a
machine learning engineer over at a
little company called explosion which is
the company behind spacy and Prodigy um
spy is very well known for being an NLP
tool and pro is a data labeling tool
that's the company I work at so I
actually deal with this whole problem of
uh how do you learn as much as you can
from data which is kind of in this
Active Learning space um and basically
what the whole premise of the problem
that most of our users face is that um
you have this big bucket of unlabeled
data and at some point you want to get
this fancy machine learning model and by
golly it'd be great if we had some sort
of trick to get there and then um when
you go online and you ask the internet
like what should you do uh the internet
says active learning uh it's in all the
textbooks even nowadays so Active
Learning is probably the thing you got
to do and the goal of this talk is to
dive into that uh idea a bit more but
it's also to suggest some other ideas
that might be worth considering as well
that might have been
overlooked before getting to that uh
let's just discuss uh what active learn
typically means so um what I'm going to
assume is that we have some sort of data
set uh all of that is unlabeled but what
we could do is we could maybe do some
sort of a random start maybe sample the
first 100 data points or so and let's
say this is a text classification task
so like we have a sentence and then a
label and maybe for like 100 random
examples we can get like a little data
set and maybe train our first
model now this model might not be very
good but a classification model can give
us probability values so like when you
do predict proba s could learn you get
these probability like values that sum
up to one and some people like to
interpret that as a measure of
confidence that in turn can be used to
create a subset the thinking is that if
you pick the uh examples from the
original data set that aren't labeled
where the model is the most uncertain so
for binary classification the confidence
is really close to
0.5 then maybe those are some examples
that the model can really learn from You
could argue those are the most confusing
examples so to say and then you've got
batch one and two the first batch was
made by a random start but the second
one was actually informed by the model a
little bit and that means that we can
train the second version of our model
and as you can kind of maybe get a feel
for it this is something you can
actually keep on repeating so you can
keep on asking the model as it sees more
data like hey what are you most certain
about and let's focus in on
that you did this for a while you keep
on doing this and and the hope is of
course that if you do like getting
annotated data this way this is going to
be much better than doing just random
search and sampling randomly that's the
hope so a really good question is to say
like all right you know sounds plausible
but is this idea really perfect like
does it always work can I just follow
these ideas
blindly and to answer that question the
thing that I hope people still do is
what I always do is I just try to
Benchmark it just really do like a very
simple hey can I confirm that the basis
of this idea at least works and one way
to Benchmark is to grab just a random
data set from the internet but you can
also just use the make classification
function inside a Psy could learn it's
not perfect or anything like that but
like it's a theoretical Benchmark that
anyone should be able to simulate just
from
scratch so I made a data set um and then
I make this chart uh on the x-axis you
see the number of data batches that have
been generated and annotated on the y-
AIS you see the performance of the model
and I've done this like in a couple of
rounds and like the blue lines the blue
dots I should say those indicate samples
where Active Learning took place so you
can see that in this particular instance
um the blue lines or dots are just a
little bit higher than the orange ones
in general so you can look at this and
you can kind of go all right kind of
seems to work like the active learning
thing is doing what it's supposed to do
but then you change the settings then
you get a chart that looks like
this
and this is always fun like it's always
fun to kind of see if you can break it
if you can break like if you can break
something in practice that's really
robust against breaking something in
theory but it does help to at least take
a step back and think about why this
might be the thing on the left seems
good the thing on the right seems bad
and maybe if we understand that we are
much better off doing active learning
stuff so this isn't a grand unifying
Theory of Everything But what I will
just try to highlight is some settings
in this setup that cause the one chart
versus the other
one so again we do the random start in
the beginning we have our first data set
we train a model we do probas we make a
subset we repeat this a whole bunch of
times but if you want active learning to
perform worse one thing you could do is
when you call make classification say
that there are more than two classes
like introduce way more classes to the
problem and
apparently something about that makes it
harder for the active learning thing to
do something right another thing you can
also do is you have that start data set
that you start with that first random
sample and turns out if you make that
kind of small like the first set you
give the first model if that's like a
relatively small set turns out that
that's also more likely to make act
Active Learning
worse there we go uh and another thing
that you could can also do is make the
batch size really really big that's also
something that you can do that at least
from like playing around in a notebook
seems to have an
effect now those are just observations
but one sort of theory you can have when
looking at this is you can say well
maybe if I have like one random start in
the beginning with lots of classes which
is kind of a harder
problem then maybe the model can overfit
on that because we are using probos from
that first model to determine
what the sample next so maybe that first
batch actually matters a whole lot and
maybe that's a local optimo that's kind
of hard to escape if you keep on sort of
reinforcing what is uncertain in your
feature
space right there's maybe some other
stuff that's also happening but at least
plausibly I hope you can imagine that
there's actually quite a few
hyperparameters to
this and it's not just Vincent doing
something fun in a notebook there's
actually papers about this that you can
read as well this one was particularly
fun and interesting to read the title is
practical obstacles to deploying Active
Learning um and the authors do a couple
of clever things um the paper is full of
tables like the one you see over here
basically this is just they try out a
whole bunch of data sets and they try
out a whole bunch of approaches um and
if I read this correctly the color
indicates if Active Learning was better
or if random sampling everything was
better um blue indicates that the active
learning approach was better and red
indicates that just sampling randomly is
way better it's not not actually way
better because the differences between
active learning doing better and uh
random doing better are like really
small but you do look at this and also
kind of go well it's not necessarily
obvious that this is all like the right
color maybe Active Learning fills here
in a bunch of data sets as well and what
they were also able to confirm is that
uh all of these uh problems were text
classification problems they found a
general pattern that is not really
certain that it helps out a
lot but then they also tried out entity
recognition which is finding substrings
in a sentence like find all the person's
names uh find all the organizations find
all the python packages like you're
interested in a substring um for those
problems it actually did end up being
beneficial somewhat marginally like it
wasn't like an earth shattering
difference or anything but you could at
least argue empirically that yeah a
couple of percentage points they get
added
so you
know can we learn something from this
because again if I to me it's pretty
clear we can't trust that Active
Learning will fix everything but maybe
if we learn something from this we can
at least come to approaches that might
be somewhat
beneficial and one Dynamic that I think
is pretty interesting to zoom in on is
the fact that you can overfit in the
beginning and also if you have batch
sizes that are very very big
maybe you want to do that maybe in a
more micro fashion instead where uh sure
you have some sort of beginning but
maybe we try to learn a little bit every
time instead of learning everything from
a huge
batch and that kind of brings us to how
you want to train machine models uh in
the first
place because if I think back of you
know how people might have sampled this
um we have our first data set then we
train the model the second data set has
match one and two then we train a model
you can do that for the third item as
well what you'll notice that this
actually might be expensive because you
are training a model from
scratch because you have a new data set
you're going to call fit predict on the
thing again that's actually not a cheap
operation to
do what's more imagine that we now use
the probas for this and apply those
probas to the original data set and then
we sort everything that's also kind of
expensive you think about all the
operations because you're making the
same prediction over and over again for
lots of examples you're not going to
sample
anyway so
let's maybe consider doing something
like this the original idea is that you
train in batch so the idea is somewhat
new data set start from scratch train
fit predict proba go another thing you
can also do is you can say well I have
my data set batch like I'll call that
you know batch one then I'm going to
learn a model and I'm going to keep the
weights of that model around such that
when I get like a second subset
instead of retraining everything from
scratch maybe I just have a neural
network that trains for like one or two
Epoch on that new data
set and the whole thinking here is that
as people are annotating in an interface
maybe if we only have to train one Epoch
we don't have to like shut down the
server in order to retrain the system we
can kind of do it more in an online
fashion and when you do that there's
actually some fun things that you could
do right so imagine there's like a
stream of examples that come in kind of
more in the online learning setting um
you you can observe a data point that
comes in you can kind of um pass that to
the model the model makes a prediction
and then you can kind of do two things
like either the model says well I'm
super confident about this item or
whatever reason that it's not
interesting then you can say well let's
just move on to the next example
then but maybe the example for whatever
reason is interesting either because of
confidence or whatever reason you might
have maybe it's a rare example right
that could also be a reason but then you
can say okay then that sample is going
to go to the user for annotation and
then when we get that annotation maybe
in like very small batches then we
update the model and then we get to the
next
example obviously this is also not going
to be perfect but the thinking is that
there might be some numerical aspects to
doing this in batch that do get remedied
when you do it this
way from my perspective one thing that
is actually kind of nice about doing it
this way is that you never have have to
shut down an annotation server this is
something you might be able to do on a
separate thread or at least somewhat on
the fly so you never have to really shut
down something in order to retrain a
whole system you can kind of do this uh
on the
fly but still also in this case the
first few examples are going to matter a
whole lot you can be picky in your first
sample and you can still get stuck in
the local Optima another downside of
this approach is that not every
algorithm can actually learn on a stream
there's a reason why psyched learn has a
fit predict API
sometimes it's just really convenient
that you're able to do this on a
batch and especially if you're doing NLP
uh not every Library will be robust
against this if only because the
vocabulary uh what do you do when you
see a new word that you've never seen
before there are approaches that can
deal with this um there's a lot of cool
hashing stuff that you could do but
sometimes if you're doing text
classification the vocabulary cannot
really update like not every Library
properly supports that so even even
though I can argue that there are some
cool things about this approach also
here it's not like there's a free lunch
you still got to be a little bit
mindful
so there's also another
thing we can take tons of unlabeled data
and we can apply Active Learning we get
our fancy model but it also helps us
take a like small step back and think
about this from like a very sort of meta
theoretical angle to see if there's like
a potential for like a silent failure as
well cuz there
is so uh okay how do you do ml well even
if we have a data set that's you know
somewhat reasonable that has some
annotations like binary classification
or whatever then we still think that
making a train EV validation set is a
pretty good idea like uh you can run
your data on the train set and you can
judge the model on it but it's kind of
like
cheating we do have this consensus that
having some sort of evaluation set SE SE
from the set that actually sees the data
while training is a pretty good
idea but how do you decide what goes
into the validation set and what goes
into the train
set I might argue and again there's
considerations but I might argue that
you want the validation set to resemble
reality as much as
possible because you're evaluating on
that set so it makes sense that you're
going to go for something that really
mimics reality as much as you can even
if it's not
perfect conversely you also want the
train set to be resembling the
validation set like if you're going to
train on something completely different
than what's in your validation set you
know you're also going to be in a
pickle so that's why a lot of people say
that you want these train sets and
validation sets to be sampled
independently of each other just
randomly basically so that feels like
the most pure way to go about
this um but what does active learning
actually do well Active Learning takes
the model that's just been trained to
determine the next data Point's the
sample that goes against this
principle so I I showed you charts right
where I had like a validation set and
like I would show which model performs
best but the moment you actually do this
in practice where you're really starting
from scratch you got to be careful here
because the number that you get out of
your system is determined by this
phenomenon and there might be this
situation where you get the impression
that your metric is really good because
your validation set contains all the
samples that your model is sampling
right now and might not resemble reality
because Active Learning is not the same
as sampling
independently so internet says do Active
Learning but I would argue here that we
should also remember it's not going to
be perfect there's definitely like
little snakes under the tall
grass so um okay what if we take a step
back back uh mainly because always when
I find myself in like a theoretical
conundrum I try to take a step back as
much as possible and try to think of
like all the chest pieces on the board
and see if there's like a maybe bigger
pattern to what we're doing sometimes
it's it's easier to dive into details
but sometimes it's actually nice to let
details go and see if there's maybe more
General something uh taking
place so I might argue that um from a
very high perspective Active Learning is
basically using a trained model Ro to
prioritize the examples that haven't
been annotated
yet at a very very high level like
forget about the proba details but
that's kind of what we're doing we're
saying we've got a bunch of stuff that's
unlabeled we have some sort of machine
learning model and we're going to try to
use that model to like figure out what
to do
next but what if we look at it slightly
differently what if we say well in the
beginning there's like not enough data
to learn from but maybe we can also look
at picking the data set that we want to
use and giving that particular data set
to the model maybe that's
teaching because you could argue like
hey hey model this is the stuff I want
you to look at first go and it's kind of
a way to steer the model maybe and it's
something that I as like the algorithm
designer tend to have a lot of influence
on so maybe we shouldn't look at like
this one system of active learning
that's like the way to get new
annotation examples Maybe maybe we
should say well yeah You' you've got the
trained model trick but there's tons of
other tricks that will also find
interesting subsets for
you and maybe that's the most important
thing to
realize because if we think about it
from a perspective of hey we are
teaching a model here that also empowers
you as the model of the human a bit more
because you get to decide what's
important for this model and active
learning might be a useful trick but it
might also be nice to just see how far
we can stretch our creative freedom
here and um I think I have time right
we're kind of okay on time so what I
would like to do is just show you two
tricks uh that in my mind fall into this
active teaching category that are kind
of out there but are also just super
neat uh stuff that I found out while
working uh at my company last year uh
one of them is a single label umap trick
and the other trick is that making
mistakes can often lead to
profit so I'm going to be a bit hand
wavy here but here's the needs
trick let's say that you've got a set of
images and we have hugging face or
whatever source to give us embeddings so
image goes in numeric array comes out
tons of different ways to do this but we
have methods for
this probably something deep learning
machines go bur but you get some sort of
vector and you can kind of assume that
if two vectors are similar the two
images are probably also similar tons of
ways to do this but we have these pr-
models so okay we've got this
what I could do then is instead of
having an n-dimensional array I can turn
it into a two-dimensional array you can
do that with principal component
analysis PCA my favorite trick is umap
um there's lots of different ways to do
this but the cool thing about having a
two-dimensional representation that
somehow still links back to the old
representation is that you can make a
scatter chart and you get these blobs
you get these
clusters but what if now right given
that we have systems that can do this
but what
if we only sample images that have the
same
class right so uh we have some sort of
model and the model says oh these are
all the
dogs so I only sample images that are
supposed to be dogs and then I look at
what the scatter chart looks
like they can kind of Wonder well if
they're all the same label they should
be all like kind of similar so maybe I
should expect a single blob to be there
and if there's not a single blob but
very clearly there are four blobs let's
say what does that
mean a lot of details depend on like
which embedding Library you use and like
there's lots of details here but I hope
that you do feel this thing of like hey
yeah if the scatter chart shows very
clearly distinct different
clusters that's at least worth an
investigation um so I made a tool that
actually is pretty good at this and uh
one of the users on GitHub actually
showed me a really cool demo uh that I
would like to show to you as well so uh
what I'm about to show you is I'm about
to show you a scatter chart um as well
as some uh uh images inside of that
scatter chart and uh hopefully you can
all see this yes uh the images that
we're about to look at are from this
website quick draw um this is a
experiment by Google where users get
like text and they got to draw that in
10 seconds so the Doodles are are like
not always perfect but um you can
download this data and you can say give
me all the pictures of Mona
Lisa and then what I can do is do the
umap trick I've done that beforehand and
I can say hey uh let's open that up in
bulk it's the tool that I made and what
you can see here is that if you look at
all the
Mones there's kind of like four
clusters so let's zoom
in
uh art ain't it a beauty okay so but
these are faces so I can kind of go like
all right this could be a Mona
Lisa what are the other clusters then
doing oh right it's m in a frame okay I
kind of get that what are the other two
clusters
doing right so this is a frame with two
lines all right
what's
this oh right so users sometimes submit
gibberish because there's not enough
time to actually draw this thing okay
let's label this right uh this is very
much again the human is in the loop but
this is for me a very good reason to
prioritize a subset uh because this
should not be happening I can definitely
um sympathize with the other clusters
that I see like the frame yeah okay that
has an influence on the embeddings sure
but this feels too distinct and just a
quick Glimpse already tells me this is
not the Mona Lisa we got to relabel
this and I don't need active learning to
do this right that's also kind of a cool
way of thinking about it another cool
thing about this trick by the way is
that um you can look at this trick as
kind of like an active learning thing
where the we don't have a large data set
just yet but it can also be seen as like
a hindsight thing for data quality like
maybe um if someone gives me a label
data set I should just do this exercise
to make sure there's no G fuffle in it
CU a lot of these public benchmarking
data sets do have issues in them and
just the fact that we can say well it's
supposed to be a single label that's a
good
juristic also you can pip andall bulk
it's useful for stuff like
this there's also other stuff that we
can do though uh and that brings me to
like a new project of mine um I have a
website called Vincent's archive front
page the whole point of Vincent's
archive front page is that this is a
front page of the internet for me of
stuff that I'm interested in there's a
bunch of classifiers uh it's deployed on
GI up Pages it's a GI up action job
every day I scrape archive to see if
there are papers about topics that I'm
interested in one of these topics is new
data sets sometimes people release a new
data set that's just kind of interesting
because it's unconventional and does
something that I typically don't do for
example there is the chess vision data
set um there's this uh 3D animation tool
called blender that has a python API and
people use that to programmatically
generate uh chess boards with chess
pieces on it such that they could have a
data set that can then be used to like
whenever someone makes a photo of a
chessboard to figure out what the uh the
patterns are so to
say this also comes with like a model
this is like okay this is stuff I would
like to see like Twitter is not what it
used to be anymore finding these
articles is nowadays kind of hard so I
made this tool but U to things that are
cool is one I actually see these cool
papers but also I built this in such a
way that um the classifier works on
sentences so it also is able to
highlight the sentence that makes the
classifier go o this is something
Vincent might like so I get this little
confidence indicator over here I get
this little highlight so this is telling
me so I can look at this and kind of go
all right this is legit like this is
fine sometimes though it also doesn't do
what I want so there's a paper here
called a novel neural network based
Federated Learning System for imbalanced
and non-id data interesting topic but
it's not about a new data set and then I
look at why the model thinks this and
it's like we evaluate our proposed
systems on five well-known Benchmark
data sets and yeah I can kind of get
where it's going wrong here because
sometimes a benchmark data set is about
a data set but it's not
new so that's a mistake from the
classifier so maybe instead of doing
Active
Learning how about I go to all my
unlabeled examples and I just go find me
more sentences like that because that's
the thing that my model does wrong right
now again I don't need active learning
for any of this but I would just like to
get more samples like this just so I can
push against the model believing that
this is what I
want and you know I am a big believer in
U yes code tools so if you go to the
front page thing that I made it comes
with a command line app and I can say
that I want annotate some new
data um there's a couple of topics that
I can pick from I want the new data set
topic I want to make predictions on a
sentence level I'm going to use this
tool that I made that is approximate
nearest neighbor look up I give it the
sentence that I want and then machine
goes BR and in the background it's doing
like the index lookup it's trying to
find examples like this one where it's
about a benchmark data set and if I open
this extensive experiments on Benchmark
data sets demonstrate the effess of our
proposed method yeah this is a sentence
that's very similar to what I saw go
wrong but it's also a sentence I don't
want to have labeled as new data set so
I can say no very similar sentence I can
say no I can say
no Etc right but this is the point here
is this is not active learning this is
active teaching I am well aware of the
problem that I want to solve I want to
steer the model towards behavior that
I'm interested in and maybe just
thinking about this as an active
learning problem and I should think
about it that way maybe that is the
biggest constraint
here and that's also kind of the point
so just to name a couple of active
learning techniques that you could go
ahead and use um for the first batch you
can sample randomly but you can also do
your best to just sample as wide a net
as you can like do K means and take
those centroids like make really make
sure you don't get stuck in the local
Optima that's a technique you can do if
you're doing stuff as you go uh maybe
the stuff matters more than the old
stuff so you can try to do that um you
can focus on examples where the model
gets it wrong what you can also do is
have two different models that are both
good but when they disagree something
interesting might be happening so sample
more of
those lots of Tricks but the main thing
I hope that is cool about all of this is
that when you do active teaching when
you try to teach the model the behavior
that you want you are in the loop you're
still behind the steering wheel which
also means that you yourself are
learning and maybe that's half of the
beauty that we're talking about here the
use of ml here isn't just to make a
prediction it is also meant to
interactively increase your own
understanding and that's I think a very
beautiful main point when you're trying
to make models you should really Grant
yourself some creative freedom here um
there's definitely more than one trick
and you want a solution that fits your
specific problem so I really recommend
you to think about your own teaching
tactic here and to maybe iterate from
there and maybe that's something that we
can celebrate we don't have to stick to
one trick all the time we can also apply
some natural
intelligence one more
thing so um active teaching is really
cool and we kind of need more good data
sets as well and it just so happens that
I work at a company that does stuff in
that
domain um so you can imagine that it's
very tempting to me to maybe see if we
can do this collaborative thing where
together we try to get this lovely an a
data set for a bunch of tasks not just
for my own front page but there's like a
couple of I think Community data sets
that could do the community a bunch of
good so um come talk to me after I do
have to like I have a kid who needs to
go to bed and I'm the only one who can
manage that so like I do have to leave
early but after this talk I'll be around
here for another hour and if any of you
are interested in doing some active
teaching with me my boss actually
promised me an annotation cluster and
there are some data sets that I want to
annotate and make public and I promise
you everything that we'll annotate
together will be on public uh we can
also do some cool stuff with annotator
agreement when we do this uh but I just
want to publicly announce like I have
some data sets that need annotating and
if people want to join in and learn come
talk to me because I think there's some
cool stuff that we can
do thanks for listening ask me anything
about these projects and I guess the
final thing that I want to say um
there's a friend of mine in the audience
called Tunda and like right before this
talk I couldn't really get lunch she
went to the Albert Hind to give me like
an egg and cheese sandwich so if you're
all going to clap could you please clap
for her because that was like the nicest
thing
[Music]
so Tunda thanks everyone else to ask me
anything kind of want to say
[Applause]
thanks oh uh and I've got stickers if
people you
know ah the stickers is always the one
good hope this was useful yeah we have
five minutes for questions so
yeah guys all right thanks for the
lovely
talk have you done some experiments with
the online learning part and and maybe
compared it to the active learning just
to see what you know what happens if you
use the techniques that you described
have you do you have a sense for that um
a bit so the general underbelly feeling
that I have is that active teaching like
taking a step back thinking cretive that
beats everything so with that in mind
I've done some minor things
but I would also argue here like the
reason that I think the online thing is
kind of interesting more has to do with
the fact the process can continue
because the update doesn't take so long
like retraining a model from scratch and
sorting the empty no
annotation that's just the bottleneck so
the main thing that the online learning
provides is just that um still uh again
think more about your own problem I
think that's the more useful thing to do
and zooming in too much on Active
Learning can also be a distraction
that's kind of my main lesson
thank you um could could still be some
some cool benchmarks though so if anyone
has tried stuff like do tell me like I
would be
interested next
question you
also so at the end you mentioned uh like
the disagree measuring disagreement
between models y do you think the uh the
new foundational models like segment
anything are valuable in there hm if
only someone wrote a blog post about
that large disagreement modeling yeah
that sounds like a interesting blog post
so this is definitely uh a pretty
awesome thing so uh on the Spacey side
of things we've got two people on the
Spacey llm team now so we've made a
Spacey plugin where you can basically um
give us your labels give a description
of the label give us a couple of
examples that the LM did wrong before uh
we will then configure the LM that you
like we integrate with a whole bunch of
back ends that model can then be
compared against your own local Spacey
model and we also have annotation
recipes that help you figure out hey
when do they disagree so you can
annotate those first and I will
definitely say I think that's the
coolest llm trick so far because the llm
for if you're doing stuff with text the
llm will kind of guarantee although it's
not cheap maybe but it will kind of
guarantee that you always have a second
model so you can always do this trick
and the cool thing as well is that when
you do differences between models you
also don't want the two models to be
almost the same like it's it's kind of
like saying oh I've tried to run forest
and XG boost and when they disagree I'm
going to do something but they're kind
of the same here I could argue that the
way that uh Spacey might go about it if
you have like a convolutional model with
vectors is quite a bit different to the
way that the LM would deal with it so
when they disagree that's probably
interesting either I will have either
I'm going to uh expose myself to
examples that improves The Prompt or I'm
going to have examples that will improve
the model uh which is also good um the
blog post has fancy
diagrams uh but this like yeah the model
disagreement with llms is a legit use
case I think especially with the Adin of
more and more of these models being uh
local on your disc and also the ability
to fine tune and there's still like a
lot of work to do in that domain of
course but just the fact that this is
available as a starting out Trick I
found that to be pretty good especially
if you're dealing with named
entities um because this usually
involves a whole lot of clicking around
and just having models that can do this
for you usually makes it a lot quicker
to annotate data as well yeah that LM
stuff in this domain I think is a pretty
legit use case also because there's a
human in the loop and we've got some
pretty good results here thanks U I
should say about that one thing about
this though um in the beginning the LM
performs better than the Spacey model we
found but there's something about the
threshold of 2,000 examples or so where
usually the Spacey model actually
performs a bit
better my theory there and if this
depends on the data set not this is not
like a whole encompassing saying but one
thing I can imagine is that the LM is
really supposed be a super General thing
and your model is usually supposed to be
a very specific
thing so that does help explain that in
the beginning the LM might be better but
the moment you reach a threshold of a
couple thousand data points the local
spacing model can actually perform a lot
better as well something to keep in mind
like LM is not always better okay thanks
we have time for one last question
anyone in the
back there someone to the front
here okay good guess
uh yeah I was thinking about that about
database data set size because like the
fact is that we have tons of unlabel
data and we always think that the
solution is okay let's find an algorithm
that can allow us to use all the data
said but from what I was seeing from
your example your last example about the
tool sometimes it's more about having a
few examples about good
labels and can you can you elaborate
about saturation of performance with the
it size I I guess like an extreme
example here is say I've got one image
of a dog I've got one image of a cat I
can rotate them slightly boom I've got
thousands of
examples okay on paper I've got
thousands of examples is that really
going to lead me to a good
model Maybe not maybe the data set also
needs some
diversity um so one way to think about
it is you want to have a data set that's
specific enough to your use case such
that you don't apply lessons you don't
need but you still need enough diversity
and does like the number of examples
capture that or should you just make
sure that you've got like a couple of
distinct
clusters uh like that's also another way
of thinking about it at least and again
um when I apply this trick where I just
look at what kind of mistakes does it
make usually it's not like all these
mistakes are from one cluster so to say
there's actually a kind of a wide Varity
of mistakes that it makes
um so
again natural intelligence like think
about the problem iterate uh try to
understand why certain mistakes are more
prevalent than others and just repeat
maybe that's better than hoping an
algorithm will solve it
yeah thanks so natural intelligence is
all you need it's maybe like a good good
statement too I would like to thank snet
for coming here for this amazing talk
and introducing us to Active Learning
please reach out to him active teaching
active teaching yes not learning
teaching so I hope everyone got
something out of this talk and apply to
their own fields for more information
please feel free to reach out to Vincent
and also check out his LinkedIn page uh
please give me a huge round of applause
before
[Applause]
[Music]
leaving